The volume of data
within and outside of companies
has never been greater.
Professionals who are able
to turn data into intelligence
are in high demand
in the market.
Udacity has created a course
so that you can gain
all the knowledge needed
to make data-driven
decisions.
You will learn
the fundamental concepts
of data gathering, treatment,
and visualization
and use these information
for your benefit.
You'll also be able
to reveal trends,
foresee demands,
express correlations
and simplify the understanding
of huge volumes of data
for everyone.
These skills
have become so essential
that companies such as Airbnb
have already directed their efforts
towards educating their entire
teams in Data Science.
The Data Science Foundations II
Nanodegree program
was created
by partner companies
who boast expertise
in Data Science.
You'll learn quickly
things like Statistics, Big Data,
R Programming,
predictive models and more.
The course also has
special participation
of Data Scientists from
Google, Twitter and Netflix
who can illustrate concepts
with their experience.
You'll also learn to use
data visualization
to communicate your insights,
tell stories,
and you'll see that
it's a very powerful tool
to explore your data.
What's cool is that you'll apply
everything you've learned
to two real projects.
These projects will be reviewed
by Data Science Specialists
who will give valuable feedback
for your development.
And all this practical knowledge
will make a real difference
in your career.
Master the basic
Data Science concepts
and make
more effective decisions.
Sign up for the
Data Science Foundations II Nanodegree
and take another step
in your Data Science,
Machine Learning
and Artificial Intelligence career.
DATA SCIENCE FOUNDATIONS II
DATA ANALYSIS AND VISUALIZATION